gonna go now to Ed O'Keefe who's
covering a senate debate in Ohio
happened last night and had a guided
heated with Republican J.D Vance and
Democrat Tim Ryan both on the attack
it sure did Tony good morning the race
to fill an open senate seat in the
Buckeye state is among one of the
closest this year making televised
debates like the one last night an even
bigger deal as they could tip the scales
in either direction to make feisty
quickly on the economy the opioid crisis
crime how to deal with China and
political extremism Ryan accused Vance
of being too cozy with former president
Donald Trump while Vance noted that
Ryan's voting record lines him up with
President Biden and Congressional
Democrats most of the time those attacks
are to be expected but this exchange on
abortion got especially personal when
talking about the case of a ten-year-old
Ohio girl who had to go to Indiana for
abortion Services due to Ohio's six-week
abortion ban that was in effect at the
time
if you get raped JD Vance and others are
going to say you have to have that baby
State mandated pregnancies for a rape
victim that is so far out of the
mainstream it's not even funny that poor
girl was raped by an illegal alien
somebody that should have never been in
this state in the first place you voted
so many times against border wall
funding so many times for amnesty Tim if
you had done your job she would have
never been raped in the first place
that exchange and last night's debate
overall is emblematic of what our
Battleground tracker has shown abortion
is a driving topic for Democratic voters
and Republicans like Vance are trying to
keep the focus on crime immigration and
the economy that fires up his
conservative base and remember in Ohio
early in-person voting begins tomorrow
so does absentee voting so a contentious
debate like last night could be fresh on
voters Minds Tony now more than 15
states by the end of this week will be
voting early or by mail election day
which is 28 days away
a lot of contrasting policies and
contrasting characters for voters to
sort through Ed thank you very much